speaking of elections and who would have
won
Republicans are fixated on winning by
any means necessary
quick antidote 2004 I was living in
Florida and I was purged from the rolls
I was not able to vote
so I decided personally what I was gonna
do was I was gonna make them regret ever
purging me from the volz I were up from
the polls because obviously I was a
legitimate voter who had registered to
vote but I digress
so I mobilized about a hundred and fifty
people to go vote for me yeah I let them
know that I had been purged and I wanted
them to vote for me I don't know how
many of them would have voted anyway
maybe like 10 percent would not have but
still the point is I was able to make
that impact but that's just one anecdote
that's probably absolutely not the norm
it is the exception and what's going on
with Republicans now it's the same thing
that's been going on for years they are
focusing like a laser on some specific
races including Florida Georgia and
North Carolina and they are purging
those voters at high rates this is
according to a report from the Brennan
Center you can find it on Brennan
Brennan Center org the report is from
Kevin Morris and Mira Perez it just came
out on yesterday and I want to read a
couple of quotes from it so that you can
understand what's going on quote earlier
this summer when the Brennan Center
released a report examining voter purge
data through 2016
we found that four million more people
were purged from the rolls between the
federal elections of 2014 and 2016 then
between 2006 and 2008 much of that
increase came from states where
previously that were rather previously
required under the Voting Rights Act to
get election changes cleared in advanced
before that part of the law was
eviscerated by the Supreme Court in 2013
now let's pause here there's a lot more
to read but I want to make I want to
make a point here the courts absolutely
matter because the courts have the
ability to be a final decision
in so many critical issues including the
Voting Rights Act in I believe Shelby
County County versus holder if I'm a
memory serves me correctly was the case
that allowed states who previously
because of the history of segregation
and discrimination and voter
disenfranchisement of minorities they
were required to check with the Justice
Department in order to make any changes
as soon as that was eviscerated in 2013
the phrase from brendensen org
we saw state after state after state
that one time had to get approval begin
to act in very nefarious activities with
regard to disenfranchising Communities
of colors communities of color and
marginalized communities in general
because they know that these communities
generally vote with the Democratic Party
instead of saying let me make an appeal
to these communities they say we don't
want to change who we are the Republican
Party saying this we're not gonna change
there's nothing wrong with us our
bigotry is fine or homophobia is fine
our xenophobia is fine and those people
they don't really have any legitimate
qualms they don't have anything wrong
they don't they don't have any
legitimate excuse to not support us so
what we're going to do instead of
changing our bigoted policies we're just
going to make it impossible for them to
vote and this is exactly what's being
done in three key states these are
important races that are coming up every
race is important but all of this
leading up to this critical juncture
where you can elect a progressive
candidate in Florida Andrew Gilliam in
Georgia as well as in Florida the first
black governor's potential for the first
african-american governors I mean we're
still we're in 2018 and we're still
getting the first you know which is
which is obscene but here we are Stacey
Stacey Abrams in Florida I mean in
Georgia and then of course in North
Carolina who have they've been facing
critical gerrymandering questions for
many years but here we are and
Republicans have shown that they are
willing to disent take away your vote
literally take away your vote
let's hone in on Florida I'm gonna read
the quote from the Brennan Center what
they said with regard to Florida and
this is what they said quote from
November 2008 to November 2010 the
median purge rate in the Sunshine State
was 0.2% I want to repeat the point 2%
that number jumped to 3.6 percent from
2012 to 2014 and new data show its
jumped again between December 2016 and
September 2018 Florida Florida has
purged more than 7% of its voters and I
want to pause there because I want you
to understand what's going on
they are purging voters they are
disenfranchising voters at an increasing
rate right they are they're not they're
not slowing down they're not doing it at
the same pace they are increasing the
rate at which they are purging voters
which means they are frantically trying
to stop entire communities from voting
this is something this is serious I mean
they are they are out there doing it
with intention with purpose and they're
doing it quickly and they're doing it at
a frantically increasing rate but let's
continue with the Brennan Center article
not only can we tell that the purges
have increased we also know where the
biggest purges are happening Harris
hindering Palm Beach and Okaloosa
counties have each been purged more than
10 percent of their votes in the last
two years Dade and Broward counties also
have a high number of zip codes that
purge at a higher rates some of those
zip codes however include military bases
or college campuses which one would
expect to have higher purge rates
because of the transient nature of the
population and because of the processes
for removing voters who have moved to
voters living in these three states and
to voters around the country check your
registration status to make sure that
you're still in the rolls if you're not
registered and think you should be call
your local election officials to find
out why there's still time to register
in many states if you have a problem I
wanted to read that last paragraph
because it is a call to action that I
think everyone knew
to take extremely seriously you need to
check to see if you have been purged
that was my mistake in 2004 I did not
check until he was after until it was
too late to to vote I mean that yeah
well yeah to vote to register and to
vote obviously and so I was stuck trying
to recruit other people to actually vote
for me and if you want to avoid that
problem and you're in these hell if
you're in any of anywhere in this
country you need to check to see if you
have been purged for any reason you have
I know here in Georgia do you have until
October I believe it's mid-october that
you have to register to vote
so check on your registration make sure
that you have not been purged and then
if you have been purged register to vote
again just go through the process and
then lend your voice to this
conversation lend your experiences to
this conversation let people know that
you were purged and in this particularly
in states like Florida Georgia and North
Carolina where the critical critical
races are coming up and these states are
run by Republicans the narrative really
is simply this Republicans are trying to
stop as many people as possible from
voting for Democrats and they will do
anything to win the next election
today's program is sponsored in part by
title which is a different type of music
streaming app that fosters the
relationship between artists and fans
and values diversity in music they offer
unlimited music and video available
completely ad free play your favorite
classics discover new artists don't miss
their upcoming benefit concert on
October 23rd titles fourth annual
benefit concert Title X Brooklyn
supports criminal justice reform in our
criminal justice system more than 65% of
prisoners serving life without parole
for nonviolent offenses are African
Americans one in every fifteen
American males is incarcerated compared
to just one in every hundred and six
white men that means that one in three
African American males can expect to go
to prison in their lifetime
all net proceeds from Title X Brooklyn
help to support charity organization
dedicated to reforming these statistics
such as the equal justice initiative
reform the Innocence Project which we've
spoken about and cut fifty past concerts
have featured artists like Stevie Wonder
Nicki Minaj jay-z and Jennifer Lopez
don't miss the free live stream of Title
X Brooklyn on October 23rd tune in
donate to the cause at tidal calm slash
Brooklyn that's tid al.com forward slash
Brooklyn